sí efectivamente María Clara es el punto
más importante lo habíamos adelantado
hay un nuevo proyecto de ley a
migratorio en el Reino Unido que va a
restringir el acceso al asilo el año
pasado hubo cuarenta y tres mil personas
que ingresaron sin documentación al
Reino Unido y obviamente es muy
importante la cooperación entre ambos
países en el Canal de la Mancha la gran
novedad es ese anuncio que hace un nuevo
centro de retención de migrantes en el
norte de Francia también esos quinientos
nuevos policías para vigilar las costas
del norte de Francia y del sur de
Inglaterra y además Ellos dicen todo un
dispositivo técnico de drones y de otro
tipo de tecnología para poder hacer
frente Ellos dicen lo más importante es
atacar a las bandas que hacen que estas
personas terminen a realizando este
viaje en el Canal de la Mancha otros
temas importantes como ustedes
mencionaban la guerra en Ucrania ese
anuncio esos entrenamientos que van a
ser los ejércitos de Francia Inglaterra
de manera conjunta a los militares
ucranianos y también esa voluntad de
ambos líderes de hacer fuerte Ucrania
para que sea ella finalmente quien
decide siquiera negociar o no con Rusia
dijo Ucrania debe ganar la guerra de
Manuel macron dice Más bien Rusia no
puede Ni debe ganar este conflicto y
obviamente reiteraron también el tema de
la soberanía energética ese interés esos
proyectos conjuntos en el desarrollo de
la energía nuclear para ellos por ahí
tiene que pasar la transición energética
en Europa y también es Independencia que
ha mostrado esta vulnerabilidad debido
al conflicto en Ucrania la dependencia
justamente que tenían los países
europeos de las energías que venían de
Rusia bueno Erika y como usted bien lo
dice estos temas que están uniendo ahora
Reino Unido y a Francia Son uno la
migración que había sido un tema de
discordia y dos el apoyo reiterado a
Ucrania al respecto de algo sobre lo que
le quiero preguntar y es que se refirió
a la ayuda y al trabajo conjunto con la
Unión Europea por la seguridad del
continente al afirmar que luego del
brexit ellos no dejaron Europa que se
espera que hagan los británicos en pro
de la seguridad Europea
Sí bueno la básicamente es trabajar en
conjunto en el seno de la otan
recordemos que Francia Hace algunos
tiempos del presidente Manuel macron
había hablado de la otan como que estaba
en estado de muerte cerebral con este
conflicto en Ucrania ha cambiado
completamente su discurso ahora Europa
habla de la Europa de la defensa Pero
dentro del marco de la otan y en ese
sentido es muy importante la unión y la
cooperación entre Francia y el Reino
Unido que son las dos potencias
nucleares miembros del Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU y por lo tanto esa
es la voluntad que se mostró hoy en día
en general quiero hablar de que hoy el
ambiente era verdaderamente de una
Reconciliación entre los líderes de
ambos países que por cierto se va a
consolidar quizás a fin de mes cuando
visite Francia el nuevo rey Carlos II